Let's see who we want to talk to
next. How about a read from Milwaukee,
read from Milwaukee or on the air?
Hey, David, how are you? I'm doing well.
So I've actually got some constructive
criticism for you, beautiful. So this
has to go back to something that you said about
I forget it was a Fox interview about China.
Fighting about how they were
how Biden wouldn't respond to.
Well, yeah, let me let me explain it so
the clip was, correct me if I'm wrong,
that someone someone alleged that if
China nuked us, Biden would do nothing.
I think the way that you said that, like you said,
if China nuked us, you know, when they talk about
nuclear aggression, generally, that means like.
You know, just showing steps of nuclear tests,
stuff like that, at least that's my opinion.
And I think sometimes you you get a little
hyperbolic with stuff specifically in that case.
Yeah. Anyway, so I just thought
I would share that. All right.
Was that it? Yeah. Oh, OK. All
right, thank you very much.
You know, I think I mean, listen, I responded
to it as I saw it. I saw it as it was being
alleged that Joe Biden is so weak on China,
he would let them nuke us and wouldn't even
do anything. And obviously, I thought
that that was a ridiculous assertion
to make. But I'll review the video again.
Thank you. All right, very good. Thank you for the
call. That's going to do it for today. I'm sorry I
wasn't able to talk to everybody, but we did talk
to lots of interesting people. We'll take a quick
break and we will take calls again in the future.